I am Daniel Desjardins, I'm Brian Bluen And I am a scout master.
We threw four, two, six in London, there in New Hampshire,
And I am a Cub master with PAC three, two, eight, five out of
Rockford, Michigan. This edition of the Scout Master podcast is
sponsored by backers like us And now the old scout master.
Well, this is the last podcast for this year And the new year
is waiting, And it's waiting for you and me and our
resolutions. Right, I don't know about you, but mine tend to go
in one year and out the other. Hey, this is. this is podcast
number 202..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green, And
just before I start with the mailbag this week, it came to me
that this is a little bit like something I knew as a child.
But let me play a little something for you. So let's
get started. Let's get started with the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green, And just before I start with the mailbag,
little something for you and see if you remember this magic
mirror. Tell me today that all my friends have fun at play. All
my friends had fun today, while I see Billy's having a special
day, And so, as Barbara can, of course, friends. you know I
see you love your friends. Have a good day. Bye, bye. Are you
hopelessly old like me? Do you remember the magic mirror?
Anyway, no charge for that, Okay. Anyway, I heard from
Kerry this past week and he said: hi, Clark, And thank you so
much for carrying on the scouting tradition in such a modern
way. I'm an Eagle Scout And my experiences in scouting
helped to set the course for my life. I appreciate your
encouragement of the organization and of the
role of scout master. Well, thank you, Kerry. Always happy
to hear that people are finding the podcast and finding it
useful. There are a couple of reviews that came through
this week for the Scout master CG app. Now the app is
available for you on either an Android device or on iPhones
and iPads. It's easy to find either at the Google Play
store or on the iTunes app store, So check it out. You can
access all the editions of the podcast. Well, eventually
you'll be able to access all the editions of the podcast. I
think we've got the first 80 podcasts in the podcast
archive right now And we're continually adding more. You may
want to join the other folks who are accessing the blog and
the podcast and all of the other resources through the app. It's
a pretty easy way to keep up. Anyway, Steven Jarvis over at
iTunes said this is a great resource for Scouters And the
app is a great way to keep all the awesome resources at
scoutmastercgcom at your fingertips. Literally. It's easy
to keep up with the podcast, blog, Twitter feed and more. Just
another great addition to the family of useful resources for
Scout leaders. Thanks, Steven. We've got a couple of new
reviews over on Stitcher. If you're not interested in the
app and you have a Stitcher smart radio, that's another
way to access the podcast. Mike 381 said: always great
content for anyone in scouting. Share this link with
everybody on your troop committee. Share it with your
favorite cup parents so that they are prepared for the
Boy Scout troop. If ScoutmasterCG says read this
book, you read it. If he says buy this book, you buy one for
yourself and copies for your favorite Scouters. Thanks
for 200 plus weeks of great podcasts And thanks to
Stitcher for making it easy to listen to. And thank you,
Mike. Also on Stitcher, Utah Scouter said this podcast is a
must for new scouts. as a scout are getting ready to make the
transition from Cub Scouts to Boy Scouts, This podcast has
provided a view into the Boy Scouting program. that will
greatly benefit me and my son as I transition from the pack
to the troop. Thanks, Utah. And we got this from best cook
And I'm not going to tell you where best is, Let's see if
you can guess, She said. I just wanted to take a moment from
my summer break to say thank you for all the time and effort
you put into ScoutmasterCGcom and your podcasts. I found
some of your diagrams while putting together a meeting a
few months ago, discovered the podcast and, as a result, I
am now hooked. In August of this year, I put my hand up
to rescue a unit. I was a guide and ranger guide in my
teens, but it had still been 15 years since I left. although
I've discovered you never really leave your right best. Your
podcasts have been a lifesaver, especially in helping me to
rebuild the patrol system. We now have three patrols of
four to five girls a piece and a thriving- dare I say,
growing- unit. Having got back to basics, elected new
patrol leaders, I now have a clear idea of taking my 2014
program towards more self government, with the
confidence that my girls now have enough basic guiding
skills to move forward and take responsibility. I'm
recommending your podcast and site to any Australian
guide leader who will listen. Thanks again- I think I
can safely say this comes from all my girls too- and
keep up the good work. Well, thank you so much,
Bess. And if you haven't guessed yet, Bess Cook is
a guide leader in Sydney, Australia. We're hearing more
from the Scouters in Australia and I think that's
just wonderful, And I'm still resisting doing my
excellent Australian accent for you all, And I'll see
if that makes, if that turns into a New Year's
resolution. But it's always good to hear from folks.
you're going to find out how to get in touch
towards the end of the podcast. I hope you're
enjoying the holidays. As I'm recording this
podcast, I'm anticipating something in our
little town's history that could prove to be
kind of significant. Now, it's no secret, I live
in a little town in southeastern Pennsylvania
called Kennett Square. Kennett Square has the
distinction of being called the mushroom capital
of the world. That's right, Mushrooms. Next time
you go out and buy a can of mushrooms or fresh
mushrooms, just take a look and see where they
come from. I'll bet they came from Kennett
Square, Pennsylvania, But anyway, somebody in
town came up with this brilliant idea for New
Year's Eve We are going to have a mushroom
drop. Now what this is is it's a giant
lighted mushroom that is going to drop from
high above street level down to the street as
we count down Allah. you know what they do
up in Times Square, but they don't have a
mushroom, They just have a ball. We have a
giant mushroom, So it's going to be kind of
interesting. It's been all over the news,
It's been on national news and things, So
we're not quite sure what to expect. I am
anticipating the first annual mushroom
drop. as I record, this podcast has
absolutely nothing to do with scouts, But I
just thought it was so interesting that I
would mention it Now. as far as the site
goes, over the holidays here I've been
working behind the scenes preparing to
launch a couple of new resources within
the next few weeks, And things are coming
together nicely. I think you find them
useful. As soon as all of those
arrangements are in place, I'm going to
let you know the details. In the
meantime, I want to let you know that
those of you who have become backers are
making all of this possible. If you're
a regular reader or listener and you
find what we are offering to be helpful.
well, you can help to by keeping
things up and running and become a
Scoutmaster CG backer. Now. funds from
backers go towards the expenses of
producing and publishing all of the
resources, including the blog and the
podcast and the videos that are
proving to be a valuable resource. We
want to keep those freely accessible to
Scouters all over the world. I want to
make sure to take the time to thank the
folks who signed up as backers over this
past week, And I've got to say I am
pleased and amazed that people are
doing this during the holidays, But
really thank you so much for your
generosity Over the past week. Jim
Gillagy, Dev McCabe, John Collins and
Michael Doemer have joined the ranks of
ScoutmasterCGcom backers, and we
sure do appreciate it. Well, in this
podcast- and it's a brief one, because
you know it's the holidays and we all
have a lot to do in Scoutmastership
in seven minutes or less, I got a
couple of questions to get you ready
for the new year, And then I have an
email question, a very brief one, to
answer, And that's going to take up the
rest of the podcast. So let's get
started, shall we
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or
less?
Well, towards the end of the year.
there's some. there's some traditional
things that happen in scouting units.
We're all just been through the big
administrative task of rechartering
our units and kind of assessing our
past year and doing the journey to
excellence and all that type of thing.
Looking back on the past year, you're
satisfied with a lot that's gone on.
If you're like me, there's going to be
some things. you're not completely
satisfied with, some things that you
know you should do better.
So if you're dissatisfied- I got this
to tell you good good, you should
be dissatisfied because the
Scouters are always striving.
If you're like me, you're obsessed with
getting things right and making the
most of the opportunities that are
presented to us.
We know that time flies and there is
so much potential and so much more to
do and there are so many
possibilities.
Now are you disappointed or
irritated or impatient?
That's not good
And you shouldn't be.
And let me tell you why.
Being dissatisfied with things
motivates us to do better.
Being dissatisfied or disappointed
with people, that can make us
irritable and impatient and grumpy,
And I think there's a big difference.
Now we accept that things are not
always going to go well and we know
that there's always going to be
room for improvement.
What we don't want to do is
confuse the impermanence and
uncertainty of things with the way
people react to them.
Any scouter can throw an
honestly deserved pity party
any time we want, right,
I mean, there is in the nature
of the work. we can look at it and
we can say: you know, I try really
hard, I do everything I was trained
to do and nobody seems to care.
And I have been there,
We've all been there before.
There are times when we are sure
that we're hitting on all eight
cylinders and stuff is going great
And there's times when nobody
seems to care at all-
Parents and scouts. they may misbehave
or game the system and they may
not act as though they appreciate our
efforts. They may take advantage
of our kindness and they may be selfish
and they may misunderstand what's
going on. I got to tell you
this is nothing new.
This sort of thing has dogged
every scouter for the past century.
It doesn't take much to go back
and to look at old scouting literature
and see that we've always had the
same frustrations.
And if we concentrate on the way
people react, that's really
frustrating. If we strive to study
and understand why they're
reacting the way that they react,
we learn how to make a difference.
That's why I think every
scouter should always have this
little edge of dissatisfaction
with the way things are going.
But we need to strive not
to be dissatisfied with the
way people are reacting.
We need to study that and see
what we can do to make things
better. It's easy to take
these reactions personally.
If it's happened to every single
scouter ever claimed the name over
the past more than a century
of scouting, it's going to happen
to you. Don't take it personally.
Just strive to make a difference,
and making a difference happens
one scout at a time,
And really I got to tell you
it really can't happen
any other way. That's why
you are so important.
That's why the work that you do
is so important. Get a hold
on the spirit of service,
not just to a program or an
ideal, so much as service
to an individual scout.
How can you make their lives
better? How can you help them
progress? What are you aiming
at? The answer is always
based on the individual scout
and for some it takes a lot
of work to understand how we're
going to reach them. I don't
think I will ever be
completely satisfied with
my work as a scouter.
I'll always strive to do better.
Most of all, I'll strive
never to allow my dissatisfaction
to be directed at the
reactions, but at the
work itself.
Maybe then I'll get to be useful:
Now what we've done over the
past couple of months and
filling out forms and
assessing how we're doing. in
that process, we're going to
discover flaws. We're going to
discover the things that we
need to work on.
Each one of those things is
not just a flaw or a
shortcoming. It's a potential
for doing better.
So welcome to
the ranks of dissatisfied
scouters. Good You ought
to be. If we look at it
through the spirit of service
to the individual scout, it's
going to be positive and it's
going to make the coming
year all that much better.
Email that is, folks, and
here's an answer to one of
your emails.
David wrote in with this
question. He said: do you have
any information on the rules
and regulations stating what
to do with money and
gear for a unit if they
disband or do not
recharge her? David, the
BSA has a what I would
call rather obscure document
called fiscal policies and
procedures for BSA units.
It was published just in
August of 2013 and
look for a more complete
post on it later this week
on scoutmastercgcom.
This is what it says about
what should happen to unit
funds and equipment if
a unit should dissolve.
If there's any outstanding
obligations, of course funds
need to be applied to those.
If there's a surplus
leftover, the charter
organization and the local
council agree on who should
hold those things in trust
pending the reorganization
of the unit or for the
promotion of the program.
In finding the answer to your
question, I found this
fiscal policies and procedures
document and, as I said,
we're going to expand on it in
a post later on this week,
So keep an eye out for that.
If you have a question
and you'd like to get in touch,
you can certainly do that,
and you're going to find out
how to make that happen in
just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for
listening to this 200 and
second edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast,
the last one for this year.
Now here's how you can keep in
touch: Go to scoutmastercgcom
and read the blog there,
And while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email.
You can also subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
or access the podcast on your
mobile device through Stitcher
Smart Radio, and you can get
details about how to do that
at Stitchercom.
Better yet, you can get the
Scoutmaster CG app on Google Play
or in the iTunes app store.
You'll have access to the
blog and the podcast right
there on your mobile device.
You can experience all the
wonders of Scoutmaster CG
dot com through the vast
panorama of social media
outlets. Join the 4600 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on
Facebook and tweet along with
the chorus of 900 plus
tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pulture Trudinous
pictures proffered publicly,
with 1200 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest.
You can watch us at
Scoutmaster CG on YouTube.
and or you can join the
400 odd folks who form the
exclusive Scoutmaster CG
Circle on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face
Facebook, if Twitter makes you
bitter, if you have no
interest in Pinterest, if you
don't put the U in YouTube,
if you minus Google Plus,
that's alright. Bunky,
Zoom into the late 1990s
and send me an email.
Yep, you can email me,
Clark Green at Clark
CLARKE
at scoutmastercgcom.
And for the last time this year,
I'm going to remind you
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or
sponsored by the Boy Scouts of
America. Hey, it's just me
talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to
Scout leaders and have a
little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun,
here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir?
Until next time.